a man basketball is taking you from
California to Florida to Atlanta and now
you're headed to the Houston Rockets yup
first thought as you become a rocket I'm
just excited excited to be a rocket
Maya Troy you guys have watched both of
your sons but of men put in the hours
and The Sweat Equity that was required
to get to this moment how proud are you
of him I'm very proud of him I like the
way men always wanted to execute he
always wanted to master all the skills
and today for him to be rewarded to
being the number four pick in the NBA
draft I know he's feeling great and I'm
feeling so good for him yeah and they're
they're no words I'm I'm happy beyond
belief so the smile is radiating amen
our analysts are talking a ton about
your athleticism and you're joining a
Houston Rockets team led by email odoka
that already has athletes what are you
excited about in terms of the basketball
as you join this organization just being
in the NBA you know playing with these
athletic guys I feel like my best brand
of basketball is you know running and
we're a young team so that's what we're
going to do what's the first thing that
you might do to celebrate that you're
comfortable sharing celebrate
oh no listen we need to fly some in and
out out here
Troy you have had a vision for both of
your sons as they enter this next
chapter of as Pros what is the vision
that you see moving forward well the
vision now is to become leaders on their
team obviously be at least First Team
all rookie and maybe compete for rookie
of the year we got big Ambitions what do
you think about those Ambitions of him
you know I think we could go bigger I
think
just try to be great well
congratulations I know we're watching
and waiting hopefully for your brother's
name to be called but congratulations
that's all you just said to me it was
crazy that we were drafted back to back
how are you feeling in this moment I'm
super excited you know I never seen
anything like this so it feels nice to
make history with the men you know
personally though Houston and now you're
headed to Detroit a team that is looking
to build culture to start getting wins
they add your athleticism your progress
on the defensive side of the basketball
how excited are you about the
opportunity super excited I'm super
excited to you know meet my coaches meet
my teammates and just grow with them you
know trying to contend you know Troy you
were a blueprint of sorts for your
brothers they heard their names back to
back they made history tonight as their
older brother as the guy in the driveway
hooping with them and beating them up
until a certain point how proud are you
of the work that they put in to get here
I mean this is this is just one of the
most amazing days I've ever been around
I mean it's a great moment I'm proud of
both of them Houston got one of them
ones Detroit got one of them ones it's
gonna be real excited to see more things
go Sr you guys have taken the path Less
Traveled in choosing OT Elite and now
you are here on draft night about to
start your professional career what
gives you confidence in your preparation
I just you know I'm always confident I
always believe in myself I'm always
going to believe in myself and you know
I know what I've worked on so that's
that's where the confidence comes from
Maya
Maya at the
house
to see that they really took that as
nine-year-olds and
made it become a reality and this is
just like amazing there are no words to
really Express how I'm feeling like a
star said to see them back to back that
blows my mind uh the world is just
opening up to um the world is there's no
limit so I'm just very excited about
what's in store so very very happy now
the real question is what are y'all
going to do about the Jersey situation
are we going front and back splitting
the teams what's going to happen I won't
be doing it right down the middle split
it right down the middle okay I'll let
him do that Mom Crystal Big Brother Troy
assar Thompson congratulations guys